Who's the best player you've
had to play against in general?
- Aaron Rodgers.
- Please talk about that.
- Oh, man.
He's phenomenal.
I remember——I could
tell you one play.
We had a practice squad guy
lined up on 17, right?
- Right.
- So I'm disguising them
kind of down towards the box
but I'm actually going back.
So, for some reason,
I'm in this stance
and I'm never in this stance.
A-Rod looked at me and smiled
and kinda gave,
like, a lil' giggle.
And then did something
with his hand to 17.
I knew it was a signal to 17.
I looked at 17, I looked
at my guy that's covering him.
I said, "S--t."
As soon as he said "Hut"
I tried to run
before he said "Hut."
He already said it.
I'm already out of leverage.
Touchdown to 17 over my guy.
- Man.
- So just the mindset,
his preparation for the game
his ability to move out
of the pocket
and throw off his back foot.
You never see any
quarterbacks here
besides, I think, Brett Favre
throw off his back foot
like he does.
- Right, right.
- And he's just a great guy.